es ist eine wahre höllenmaschine der
stärkste röntgenlaser der welt heißt
european xfel steht in hamburg und hat
1,2 milliarden euro kostet nach acht
jahren bauzeit geht er jetzt in die
heiße phase mit hilfe von ultra kurzen
laserlicht blitzen im röntgenbereich
ermöglicht der internationalen
forschungsteams ein bislang
unvorstellbaren blick in die nanowelt
wir genau funktioniert welche mysteriöse
dinge sichtbar machen wird und alles was
er sonst noch zum stärksten leser der
welt wissen müsst jetzt in kriegs und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
das ist der european xfel die abkürzung
steht für x-ray free electron laser also
auf deutsch in etwa röntgenlicht freie
elektronen laser mit hilfe von
ultraschnellen röntgen blitzen soll in
der anlage das sichtbar gemacht werden
was bislang im verborgenen blieb eines
der ersten experimente beispielsweise
dreht sich um proteinstrukturen auch das
filmen von chemischen prozessen ist
geplant beteiligt sind zum beispiel
forschungsteams von deutschen elektronen
synchrotron desy in hamburg stolze 12
milliarden euro hat die anlage gekostet
sie befindet sich zum größten teil unter
der erde
der laser tunnel ist 3,4 kilometer lang
und führt vom desy in hamburg bahrenfeld
nach schenefeld in schleswig holstein
beteiligt sind elf europäische länder zu
fast 60 prozent wird es von deutschland
finanziert dahinter folgt mit knapp 30
prozent russland
bundesforschungsministerin johanna wanka
hat den röntgenlaser als eine weltweit
einzigartige anlage der spitzenforschung
bezeichnet so funktioniert der
röntgenlaser european xfel es ist ein
bisschen wie beim arzt haut muskeln und
fett verhindern die diagnose ob das bein
gebrochen ist oder die rippe und so
weiter und so fort auch der röntgenlaser
european xfel soll dinge sichtbar machen
die uns bisher verborgen geblieben sind
der funktioniert allerdings wie eine
überdimensionale lupe oder ein mega
mikroskop dies bisher noch nicht da
gewesen ist um das möglich zu machen
sorgt zunächst ein teilchenbeschleuniger
dafür dass elektronen wolken aus einem
stück metall herausgelöst und
beschleunigt werden
auf einer strecke von zwei kilometern
erreichen sie dann fast
lichtgeschwindigkeit die elektronen
worten sind also unvorstellbar schnell
und energiereich spezielle magnete
bringen sie dann in einen zick-zack-kurs
so dass die elektronen licht abstrahlen
das licht ist schneller als die
elektronen und überholt sie deswegen
dadurch werden einige elektronen
abgebremst und langsamer andere werden
schneller ändern ihre bewegungsrichtung
es bilden sich gruppen beziehungsweise
scheiben die alle im gleichen takt
strahlen die so entstehende
röntgenstrahlung wird durch die
wechselwirkung mit den elektronen immer
stärker röntgenblitze
unglaubliche 27.000 intensiveren blitze
pro sekunde sollen im european xfel
entstehen sie sind unfassbar kurz dauern
weniger als 100 millisekunden und haben
eine wellenlänge von bis zu einem
zehntel nanometer also so viel wie etwa
der abstand zwischen zwei atomen in
einem molekül und das ist genau der
punkt mit diesen blitzen können jetzt
unglaublich kleine strukturen moleküle
zum beispiel beobachtet werden nur um
das unglaubliche daran nochmals zu
verdeutlichen berechnet man die blitze
auf einem quadratzentimeter fläche sind
sie zehn trilliarden mal intensiver also
sonnenlicht ich absolut unvorstellbar
diese röntgenblitze werden dann auf
verschiedene instrumente geleitet an
denen experimente durchgeführt werden
das wird mit dem european xfel erforscht
zusammengefasst können forschungsteams
mit dem konnten leser all diejenigen
winzigen dinge messen und analysieren
die bislang als nicht messbar galten
zudem können super schnelle prozesse und
extreme zustände erforscht werden
spannend also für viele verschiedene
wissenschaftsgebiete unter anderem für
die chemie physik biologie astronomie
insgesamt stehen sechs instrumente zur
verfügung an denen internationale
forschungsteams experimentieren können
biologinnen und biologen zum beispiel
können so molekülstrukturen herausfinden
der röntgenlaser macht das unmögliche
möglich brauchten forschungsteams
bislang moleküle in ihrer kristallinen
form um ihre atom zusammensetzung zu
entschlüsseln ist dies durch den
european xfel auch so möglich entweder
durch sehr kleine qualitativ
minderwertige kristalle und manchmal
braucht es noch nicht mal die um eine
molekülstruktur zu offenbaren
langfristig könnten diese experimente
dann natürlich auch über die
grundlagenforschung hinaus gehen denn
durch die aufklärung von protein
molekülstrukturen beispielsweise lassen
sich neue arzneimittel entwickeln die
forscherinnen und forscher denken zum
beispiel ganz konkret an neue
schmerzmittel oder mittel die
antibiotikaresistenzen überwinden
könnten auch im bereich der chemie
leistet der leser sensationelles mit ihm
lassen sich bislang nicht messbare
chemische reaktionen entschlüsseln
beispiel chemieunterricht manche
chemische reaktion kennt man aus dem
unterricht ist so kommt
lex dass die moleküle so schnell von
einer zwischenstufe in den nächsten
übergehen dass dies von konventionellen
detektoren bislang nicht messbarer oder
physik die intensiven röntgenstrahlen
machen es tatsächlich möglich atome zu
ionisieren ihnen also ein teil der
elektronen wegzuschießen so lässt sich
unter anderem erforschen wie sich
materie in der sonnenatmosphäre verhält
oder aber auch die eigenschaften von
plasma das eigentlich nur so kurz stabil
ist dass seine analyse bislang fast
unmöglich erschien ihr seht also das
sind also wirklich super viel
versprechen der experimente hierbei
pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden
zu den versuchen im xl wenn ihr kein
video dazu und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit
elektromagnetische schwarzes loch im
labor erzeugt da sind einem atom mit
einem neunten leser 450 von 62
elektronen weggeschossen worden
elektromagnetische hatte sich dann wie
ein schwarzes loch verhalten also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß
dabei und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran